[Music]
these are the first scoops of dirt
of a colossal project that will displace
tens of thousands of people
cut down hundreds of thousands of trees
and turn part of istanbul into an island
the istanbul canal canal istanbul
canal istanbul is the largest
infrastructure project
turkey has ever seen
[Music]
it will connect the mediterranean to the
black sea and fulfill one of president
erdogan's oldest dreams
canon istanbul
to provide a new route for tankers
sailing between the two seas
while boosting turkey's revenue at the
same time
[Music]
but the controversial project is beating
turkey's president
is
is
so why is the canal so popular and why
does erdogan want to build it anyway
[Music]
to understand why the turkish government
wants a new waterway
you have to look at the one that's
already there the bosporos
this is the only way in and out of the
black sea and the only access russia has
to the mediterranean
more ships transit the bosporos than the
sewers and the panama canal combined
but here is the strange part while egypt
makes almost 15
of its gdp in revenue from the swiss
canal and panama almost 10
from its canal turkey doesn't collect
any fees
that's because of the montreal
convention a treaty signed in 1936
that restricts military vessels from
entering the bosporus
but leaves it free for commercial
vessels in exchange
canal istanbul could change that the 15
billion dollar project will open a
second waterway 45 kilometers long
and at least 275 meters wide
ships like this the government argues
will no longer have to wait days to
enter the canal
and turkey will collect fees on them but
critics say
erdogan's dream is an environmental
nightmare
[Music]
the canal will run through agricultural
land forests
and crucial water reserves
almost
uh
this could contaminate drinking water
harm marine ecosystems
and spread the stinky smell of hydrogen
sulfide
no wonder then that the majority of
istanbul's residents oppose the project
bangladesh
[Music]
is
but such a controversy could be just
what erdogan is after
a worsening pandemic and sinking economy
have left the president sliding in
european polls
erdogan might be using the dispute to
mobilize his base
[Music]
the government also hopes to boost the
construction sector create
thousands of jobs and turn the gears of
the economy
but some argue that this strategy could
be short-sighted
istanbul's geography will be changed
forever and most citizens are unwilling
to trade there for a short-term economic
boost
[Music]
if their position erdogan might be
digging himself into a hole
he can't get out of